doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is the spectacle that fans have
come to expect from their favorite
marvel movies but despite the hype some
fans are tweeting harsh opinions here
are the brutal reviews that prove not
everyone is loving doctor strange too
plenty of movie fans have made their way
out to the theater to see doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness and the
overall response seems to be positive
many of the initial fan reactions on
twitter applauded the movie for its
stellar direction and brilliant
performances by benedict cumberbatch and
elizabeth olsen however negative
reactions are starting to hit twitter
with moviegoers who are less than
impressed and not afraid to share their
opinions we've found some of the
harshest reviews but have no fear there
aren't any spoilers doctor strange 2 may
not be the best movie put out by marvel
studios so we can understand it being
picked at but these twitter users found
no redeeming qualities and let their
disdain shine one user tweeted i did not
expect doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness to be that relentlessly awful
oh my god while another tweeted doctor
strange multiverse of madness sucks so
much it's one of the worst movies i've
ever seen and it's an mcu movie the big
shame while it's obvious that doctor
strange 2 is an mcu movie a lot of
negative responses seem to highlight
that fact which proves how much people
expect from marvel studios these days
one user was particularly disappointed
when they tweeted doctor strange was so
bad what a letdown for a marvel movie
digging the knife a little deeper was
this tweet never seen something
suffocate itself with such a hatred of
the concept of continuity before but hey
i guess the mcu is very much in that
phase so why not while some doctor
strange haters were relatively general
in their criticisms others were very
specific about where it all went wrong
after watching the film one user tweeted
doctor strange review well that sucked
disjointed weak character development
did not deliver the madness as much as
you think best part was wanda even
though her motivations were pretty weak
too utter disappointment the script
seemed to be a resounding issue for
those who didn't like the movie in
particular one tweet said words that can
describe doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness are horrible
terrible no good very bad writing
continuing with the theme of the writing
quality on display this tweet declared
gotta say as a guy who typically enjoys
every mcu thing out there doctor strange
was truly a pretty terrible movie
visually stunning but the story rioting
blatant insignificance or overall impact
and glaring plot holes were very
off-base with the mcu it was just bad
most of the negative reviews we found
involve story elements there were hardly
any criticisms about the performances or
special effects it's not surprising to
see the disappointed doctor strange
viewers compare it to their other least
favorite superhero movies many negative
reviews liken the sequel to some real
bombs which are somewhat surprising
comparisons one user referenced a rarely
talked about marvel movie at least as
bad as thor 2 fan service without heart
ruining characters stupid plot and even
the effects could have been better i'm
shocked thor the dark world is one of
the least liked movies in the marvel
cinematic universe and was only recently
dethroned by eternals as having the
lowest rotten tomato score for any mcu
project comparing doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness to thor the dark
world is a bold choice but clearly
showcases this user's problems with the
film another tweeter compared the
benedict cumberbatch flick to a dceu
film which has divided fans for years i
did not like this movie in my opinion
batman vs superman is better than this
the writing pacing and plot holes the
director not seeing one division
contributed to this combined for a bad
showing for me batman vs superman dawn
of justice definitely has a dedicated
fanbase but the zack snyder film is
mostly known for being a pretty big mess
that was heavily criticized there's no
question that some audience members left
their theaters disappointed by what they
saw but the good news is that plenty of
other fans love the final product and
can't wait to see what adventures doctor
strange will get into next
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one